EC's learning Tom Brady wants to
reconcile with Gisele Bundchen meanwhile
she's lawyering up she's my best friend
our Insider sheds new light behind the
scenes where Tom feels quote extremely
hurt and Mrs Giselle being by his side
and the models quote hired a divorce
attorney
Tom and Gisele married in 2009. she
really committed so much of her time the
last you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dream but fast forward
to 2022 she's been spotted ditching her
wedding ring while Tom quote isn't
taking things well he wants to reconcile
and was still holding out hope that they
could work things out she's amazing at
her job she is the goat as for giselle's
new legal team the source explains it's
more so quote to move things forward in
this direction and we're hearing quote
things are a bit difficult since both
a-listers have quote huge assets
it's harder and harder as you get older
because you do take on a lot more in
your life plus there's a couple's two
kids they're just the biggest blessing
twelve-year-old son Benjamin and
nine-year-old daughter Vivian I want to
try to spend my time with when I'm
focused on my job my job when I'm
focused with my family my family and I
look back at my parents and my dad mom
do the same thing for me so I think what
I was very emotional about is I do feel
maybe some guilt that I haven't been
able to do that in the same way for my
kids and I feel like I'm so driven to
succeed in football and that's taken me
away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family yeah and unretiring
from the NFL didn't seem to help Tom's
work-life balance
did you just need a vacation there was a
little more than that
uh but at the same time
um I took some time away which is always
important it's tough to make a decision
right at the end of the season
and um
you know it's just uh for
it's a big commitment to make for
football and it's not something you just
can decide I needed time signs that
13-year marriage was in trouble soon
followed everyone's got different
situations they're dealing with like
when Tom began missing football
practices so we all had really unique
challenges to our life and
you know we're
45 years old man there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on so you know you just gotta try
to figure out life the best you can and
it's a
continuous process and while they did
reunite in Miami last week amid
hurricane Ian Tom and Giselle hunkered
down in separate homes our store says
Tom quote feels abandoned in a way he
loves his family but also wants to
continue his career
[Music]
thank you
thank you